tell me about a customer where you saw
this development
where they went from dabbling and you
either say the name or not
uh but just that sort of generic profile
of somebody who was dabbling
and then what are they doing at scale
today that requires them to have
enterprise software
as opposed to putting this in a google
sheet or on notion or
some other air table whatever yeah if
you think about it the
brands are running these super large
scale creator management
influencer marketing programs in-house
before
grin what they're doing because they
want to go direct they want to own the
direct relationship
they have these lists of bunch of
different people
in google sheets they have shipping
address discount codes their product
preferences
last time they reached out to them their
social profiles
and they've got anywhere from two to
some brands that are working with grant
have 25
people in the product every day is a big
influencer and creator teams
and what they're doing before grin is
they're emailing all those people
they want to do some sort of activation
or promotion and they're
following up and saying hey we want you
to promote this thing around black
friday here's what it is
is your shoe size still this and oh is
your shipping address
still this and there's this back and
forth dialogue they then go into the
e-commerce platform
ship the product create a discount code
send that to the person and then follow
up a few weeks later to make sure that
they actually promoted the content
and promoted the product and did the
actual activation so it takes these
people
hours on end to manage these programs
with grin they sign up they authenticate
in all their tools they authenticate
their e-commerce platform
we take that process down from multiple
days to
15 to 20 minutes they just select a
group create an activation
choose the products distribute links to
those people and it really just provides
a bunch of efficiency and clarity into
their process and makes it super easy
for them to manage
what brands or types of products does
influencer marketing work for
versus just doing search on google or
buying ads on instagram or buying ads on
facebook's network
or tik tok etc i think the right the
macro trend if you think about what's
enabling this
it's this consumer attention shift from
traditional channels into mobile social
and in traditional the distribution is
cable
radio these like companies and stations
and in mobile social the distribution
is instagram tick tock youtube and
the actual shows are people like you
they're creators on social that's what
people are engaging with
so i think the macro trend is that over
time every brand in the world
will do some form of creator management
influencer marketing
where it's really gained a lot of
traction with is in with like high
growth direct
consumer brands so digitally native
brands brands like kylie brands like
fabletics warby parker all birds
a lot of those household brands that are
you know highly disruptive and super
high growers
they grew out of direct partnerships
with creators
either one to one at the macro level and
these really big
scaled micro programs how do
these influencers get paid and then what
is the law around
and the regulatory environment how is
that shaping up because there were i
know there were people who were
basically doing covert marketing they
used they had this moment in time called
buzz marketing i don't
remember that where people were doing
like covert marketing
like they would go on the streets and be
like hey can you take our picture
and the person would say sure i'll take
your picture and then it would be a sony
camera and they'd be like oh yeah this
is my sony can you hit the widescreen on
my sony
vx 1000 whatever and it was like oh and
the ftc and other people got upset about
that and then obviously instagram now is
i think putting paid programming or
something
over people's or paid partnership i
think
on top of uh stuff so tell me a little
bit about that and how the regulatory
environment
has changed and then what are people
getting paid what do influencers get
paid how do they get paid
yeah so much questions there yeah i
think first and foremost
when the like this type of marketing
this channel is fundamentally different
than
programmatic right like it's not like
buying ads on facebook or instagram
or anything that achieves scale via
reach and frequency
the reason it's different is because the
endorsement goes to a person so you
don't control the whole thing
there's this relationship that needs to
happen when the endorsement goes through
a person to the consumer like
authenticity and trust is key
the person should believe in the product
that they're using they should disclose
the brand if it's paid or not this is
like a key part because in order to keep
audience as a creator influencer like
you need to build rapport and trust with
your audience you don't want to mislead
them
so the ftc has clear guidance around
like how you disclose via
hashtags and instagram has introduced
functionality like that you mentioned
it's in paid sponsorship or partnership
i believe with the brand
that enables you to tag them so the
consumer's not confused if you're being
paid
i haven't seen a lot of enforcement
around it i know it's key like
we enable it via our product it's super
important part of how this is all
evolving
and i think it's key because the
endorsement again is going through these
people that you trust and follow and so
not only do as the brand should you
inspire belief but you also need to make
sure that you're disclosing so i think
that's a key part
and then with regards to being paid
there's a hand it depends right not all
creators are paid
often times brands are able to because
there's affinity between the brand
and the creator it's like they're just
sharing product and so they're paid in
like cost of goods and
promotional product to get them to try
they can be paid via commission
right grin and other platforms like
grant enable very clear
revenue attribution and tracking and
then you can pay creators
a portion of the sales that they
generate via the endorsement
or you can do one-to-one partnerships
and pay people long-term almost put them
on payroll whereas they're almost like a
pseudo member of your team and they're
constantly talking about you like
how nike would do with athlete marketing
got it like a retainer yeah they're
gonna do
which of those is the predominant way in
which people do that they just give free
product in exchange
for you sharing your thoughts on it
because i see a lot of influencers and
even
met people who were in my extended
social circle
and i this is when i knew this was
becoming a thing because people in my
extended social circle
started sharing clothes and
sports drinks and i started seeing the
paid partnership and i'm like
that person has another job they have a
day job or even ceos are doing it now
where they're talking about things they
get i do ads on my podcast and i read
them but which i guess has some tacit
endorsement i usually am explicit when i
say hey listen i use
linkedin jobs duh i use notion duh and
we created our own white label
approach where if somebody is a product
i use we white label them in other words
hey jason would love to talk about it
because he uses it
and he can riff on it or i could just
read your ad
straight from top to bottom and it's a
live read but not
as much of an endorsement because i
don't use the product i don't know and i
think jason the consumer knows that
and you're doing the right thing in both
of those because you're disclosing that
it's paid
and or there's a monetary exchange in
both of those that's very clear yeah
but the consumer can tell very clearly
if you're like hey i love no
shane i use notion and by the way
they're paying me for this but doesn't
mean i don't
i still love it and so i think there's
this impetus on behalf of the brand
to inspire that feeling either through
great product execution
great marketing great brand building but
also you can do that by making friends
with the people who are creating the
content and you inspire belief and so i
think that's a great example of how it
translates to the consumer
if you don't have insurance you failed
one of the first steps of being an
entrepreneur
and in brokers technology saves you time
and money prices are up to 20 percent
lower
with better coverage than the incumbents
and you can go from sign up
to quote and purchase in just 10 minutes
when you work within broker instead of
business insurance incumbents
you're not dealing with these large slow
corporations
and sign up only takes days not weeks
the process is transparent with no
opaque pricing and there are four
crucial types of startup insurance that
they cover and that you need cyber
insurance
this is in case you get hacked d and o
insurance this is for directors and
officers
if somebody does something dumb and you
get sued then there's eno insurance
some people haven't heard of this other
people know it all too well it's called
errors and omissions and it helps you
scale your business because any major
customer will want you to have errors in
emission insurance when you close a deal
and finally and sadly epl
employment practices liability this
covers harassment wrongful termination
and more
if you are running a business and you
hit any kind of scale
somebody is going to either do something
stupid or somebody is gonna feel
that they were wrongfully terminated
even if they were terrible and you fired
them with cause they can go find an
attorney to sue you you need to have epl
and you need to have all four of these
types of insurance if you're gonna
become venture-backable
and you're going to build a robust
business to instantly buy custom built
insurance for startups go to
inbroker.com twist
e-m-b-r-o-k-e-r-dot-com
twist inbroker.com twist and use my
offer code twist to get 10 percent
off